every once in a while the good lord
bestows upon us
a [ __ ] up movie we just gotta talk
about on netflix
so we're gonna watch cuties today very
excited to finally talk about this movie
yeah get that twerking dance crew all
right no no we're gonna
talk about the devil all the time
starring a [ __ ] ton of people this is
gonna be a heavy spoiler discussion
to make this one a little different and
more interesting for everyone involved
viewers and ourselves included i thought
we'd change up our format a little bit
put out a post on patreon and our
community page just to ask us questions
about it so
everyone's questions will be the driving
force
of our discussion today gonna go
strictly off of what you guys submitted
and of course with that in mind there's
some repeat
questions so you know we i kind of just
selected the ones i'm like all right
okay this one's asked a lot so i'm just
gonna go off with this one
all right basically that's how it's
gonna work today before we go into
this um i figured we should just give
our
bottom line opinions for like 30 to 40
seconds
uh each there were a few people such as
ethan
bennett who was saying how good is it on
a scale of one to ten we didn't really
talk much about this movie but so here's
my bottom line consensus on this
i would probably give it somewhere
around an 8.5 out of 10. i really liked
it a lot
every performance here i thought was top
notch
everyone was on their a game here i
really like the direction
the best way i can describe this movie
as i was watching it it was like this
sort of feels like a paul thomas
anderson movie
meets the place beyond the pines with a
gothic southern horror touch to it i
thought it was very weird
every adjective you could use to
describe
something bleak you know like nihilistic
sinister grim foreboding all those
qualities harrowing haunting
was all on display i really appreciated
this movie
a lot didn't know much about it going
into it other than the awesome trailer
that they showed on netflix but john
what are your quick
thoughts out of 10 what would you rate
it oh goodness gracious i'll probably go
around
an eight at the moment i'm still chewing
on parts of the movie but i thought yeah
it had a really terrific terrific cast a
very steady grip on its tone and its
pace even though it is deliberately
paced i found myself very easily drawn
into it it is very dark it is punishing
to a degree so i can totally understand
if that's not your cup of tea or if you
come out of this feeling like you didn't
gain anything for the experience of all
this
hardship i do think that it is
well-lived and it's a
well-told story visually i thought about
plays beyond the pines i also thought of
like
the coen brothers sort of meets like
i've heard some people
compared to like hillbilly pulp fiction
like it it does have this interesting
anthology anthology-esque
style it's a bunch of characters
colliding around a sort of idea
and so yeah as something that is a
little more outside of that box that
isn't gonna give you a solid answer at
the end or whatever i thought this was
pretty effective yeah so yeah
now it's just gonna get heavy spoiler
terrain here so the first topic on mind
uh other than most people were asking
about performances but specifically
it was undoubtedly people were asking
about our thoughts on tom holland
yes so i'm gonna go off of anissa
oliva's question here a lot of you guys
asked it like who compared to spider-man
all that she said great movie what did
you all think of tom holland in this
movie since we were kind of seeing him
in a new light from
the boy next door to this sort of
menacing character i think he did an
amazing job would love to hear you all's
thoughts
love all thank you denise i think
everyone who asked questions similar to
this terrain i thought tom holland was
excellent he does not come into this
movie until 46 minutes
i literally when he showed up on screen
i hit the
i paused it to be like wow we're 46
minutes into this movie
the benefit of it is the fact that this
uh arvin russell character
he's a little boy throughout so his
character is in the movie throughout
it's just tom holland stepping into this
movie he's not in there until then
and i thought he did a wonderful job
admittedly admittedly i'm
so used to seeing him as spider-man it
did take me
a little bit of time to stop seeing that
and to stop
comparing i couldn't help myself and
that kind of doesn't fall
necessarily on his performance that just
sort of falls on my primary association
with the actor tom holland
i'm sure a lot of people are going to
experience that though there were times
where i thought his voice was kind of
dipping in and out and a lot of people
in the community post
were specifically asking about accents
i thought for him i thought he did a
good job on the accent
i didn't think he was the best one of
the accent however
that's not to say that i thought his
performance was diminished at all
because i didn't think his accent was as
on par
with everyone else's crazy solid accent
yeah yeah it was the type of thing that
even if uh he may have not been
as on top of it as some of the other
actors i never got distracted by it i
never sat there really thinking about
his accent
and getting pulled out of the scene or
anything and yeah i thought he
lived the character really really well
and it's funny for me i actually didn't
have that problem it was like
spider-man's the only thing i've seen
him in
but i found myself pretty well just
following along with him from the get-go
his character has a lot of heft to deal
with and of everybody you see
you see his formative stuff more than
anybody else's like when you see him as
a little boy you can already kind of
tell will probably be like when he grows
up and i think
tom holland yeah knocked that out of the
park you're seeing some other i don't
know the actor's name uh but whoever was
playing the younger version of arvin
russell
when bill skarsgard was around you're
seeing that younger actor as an audience
member you're gonna be judging
tom holland's performance in the sense
of i've now
seen lived in this moment for a good not
just a flashback like
40 minutes of a movie i lived in
watching young arvin russell's
experiences
essentially forming the core memories
that tom holland's portrayal will be
working off of
so it has to feel like a natural
progression
you know you're doing a bit of a time
jump when tom holland steps into the
movie and you do feel like no that's the
same guy
yeah that's the exact same guy and
that's a bit that's a challenge
that is a challenge in and of itself and
that falls on a lot in terms of like
writing and directing but what tom
holland brought to the table here
he does have this performance i mean
yeah the movie takes place i think his
timeline is in the 60s at that point but
his performance there is a bit
of that rebel without a cause vibe even
though he has pretty good cause
throughout this whole movie he needs to
be a rebel
no he's a terrific cause yeah he does
have that kind of throwback quality to
it there were like little moments in out
that i loved the most with him
i love that scene after he beats up
those guys who have been bullying his
sister
yeah and then when he goes into the car
he gets like the
the cuts with a slight flashback of what
he was in the car with his father
yeah that performance that's when i was
like oh man he's [ __ ] good
yeah yeah you know like you're watching
all like the cool dialogue scenes and
whatnot and that scene with robert
pattinson is great obviously that
particular moment was when i when i was
like damn
he is he is knocking it out of the park
and from that moment on i mean before
that but especially from that moment on
i was lost in the arvin russell
portrayal so yeah i thought he killed it
absolutely killed it he killed a lot in
this movie yeah
and it's funny to see the spider-man
portrayals because i mean in
a way you could argue that the origins
aren't too far off
minus the spider you know fair enough i
suppose you know just spider-man had a
more like
messed up dad who inspired him to go
beat people up for the sake of his
sister
a lot of people were asking about like
who were your favorite performances and
whatnot so i'm going to go off of this
one question right here rajav sarkar a
lot of people ask similar questions
thank you
who do you think stole the show when it
came when it comes to acting i'd say
bill with that amazing accent um here's
where i feel like we're going to be in
this category for a while on this
question
okay all right yeah the reason i chose
this specific one because in terms of
the whole stealing the show idea here's
how i would describe my experience with
this movie
whoever was on screen at the time
yeah i know i felt exactly the same way
like when jason clark was there he was
stealing the show
when bill skarsgard was there he was
stealing the show or a patent
stealing this [ __ ] stealing the show
it's like whoever
was the main character in that scene was
stealing
the show everyone does a great job that
undoubtedly i
i can't fault anyone's performance they
were
all lived in and it blew my mind just
how
how creative it was it's some of the
best acting
probably the best acting i've seen all
year
out of any you know minimal amount of
new films i've seen this year yeah
yeah yeah and you specifically
referenced bill skarsgard here and it
was at that point when i was like oh
we're not going to see tom hall until
like 45 minutes into the movie when i
was thinking to place me on the pines
i don't know if you guys have seen that
movie but if you have you'll know
exactly what we're running for
mccarthy wrote place beyond the pines i
thought
bill skarsgard was excellent
fan fucking-tastic i thought he was
great yes he killed the accent and
everything
his performance was so realistic
yeah and he he gets to some deranged
spots you know yeah when they sacrificed
the dog
and everything like that which was just
so with me man i was
there's some unsettling stuff in this
movie that was shocking
undoubtedly it's a horror movie moment
when they reveal that yeah but his
performance
of how lived in it was of like getting
his experience with the war background
what the haunting site is and how this
this haunting memories manifested and
mixed in with
christian ideologies and wanting faith
into this cross that they put in like
essentially their backyard to get to
that point with this character whether
he's going to sacrifice
his dog for his wife you have to have a
performer where
earlier on in the movie you can see how
this character
got from there to there yeah exactly
yeah
yeah in such a short amount of time in
terms of like
30 minutes into the film everyone was
lived in that's the exceptional part to
it i mean sebastian stan
i have some story things i want to touch
on and
in a second with some of these
characters but sebastian stan
was also like surprised me he gained
weight for the roll
so the rubber pattern the mark of any
great actor you gain weight for gotta
gain that weight you gain weight
you're committed yes game waiter get
skinny which one are you going for
that's where it's transformative and i
feel like it's even more when you just
gain like chubby weight you know
because people put on muscle and that's
one thing but to really sink in by by
bulking up a little bit that way is yeah
perspective and that's where my mic can
go in and out of oh man this must have
been a [ __ ] because then you gotta go
back to being
a result yeah you gotta get all buff
again but i think robert pattinson
because you see his belly when he you
know
that girl's going down on him and i
think he was pushing out his belly i
don't know if he gained weight i think
he was pushing out his stomach
that was all that not working out for
the battle right there
they all played against type you know
it's easy to look at this on paper and
be like are you sure you want this guy
for this role sebastian stan
he's not a powerful dude he's kind of a
weak man he's a weak guy
in a power position who's like
struggling to keep that power position
that's why i like his portrayal that's
why i love his performance in here jason
clark
who i i thought he was all so
good he is so good jason
clark sick in this movie i i would i
want to know what that guy is really
like
because he's like i lose he's a great
performer
but he sinks so deeply into these kinds
of roles
these just perverse deranged characters
who come across
very charming but who have this angry
mean
streak inside and yeah their plotline
too as a as a piece of this sort of
anthology was
an interesting one to say the least
serial killer
couple serial killer like prostitution
cuck couple yeah
yeah that oh man that was uh that was
fascinating you know like
jason clark these are the kind of roles
he's born to play
i don't know i don't know what it is
about this guy but
when you give him twisted psychotic on
the verge of losing a kind of characters
he knows how to bring them to life in a
way that feels realistic and not
chewing up the scenery and i love this
background that you have with this guy
who
you know used to used to teach sunday
school classes and has found this new
way of experiencing the soul
capture you know because we've seen
those kind of characters before sort of
like
i mean it's not the only character's
done this but kind of like jude law and
wrote a perdition
but you know a much more psychotic
sadistic version of this character
in this time and of course of course
there's a reason why we're not really
talking about the woman that's part of
my criticism with us
likewise and of course robert [ __ ]
pattinson
oh dude oh man he he commands every
single second he is in
no matter how small this could have
easily been the kind of performance of
i get it robert pattinson you're a good
guy you can act yeah i get it man
all right let the scenery out of your
jaw yeah
like stop trying to out act everywhere
okay what made it
so impactful is like while he does get
to be the biggest one like a
swindler or a or a snake oil salesman
kinda i mean those are the qualities
that he brings to it you know yeah the
preachers in this movie generally have
that sort of drifter snake oil
quality because even uh harry melling
like the guy who plays dudley and harry
potter like even he
has a role like that and for yeah a
movie called the devil all the time and
that deals with so many people and their
relationships to
faith i do think that that's an
interesting point
to note robert pattinson one of the many
things that i thought what made it work
and didn't make it look like you're
trying to just steal the spotlight every
time you're on
screen was he's so good at connecting
with whoever he's on screen with at that
particular time he's
in the moment with that person and
that's helping to dictate his
performance
and his immediacy in the moment you know
because this could have easily been like
oh man
all those moments of delusions like all
those scenes are the ones that you only
walk away with
but i walked away with you know more of
his creepy scenes right
the quieter moments yeah the
manipulative gaslighting using religion
to
go into like a form of denial like his
scenes with lenora
um because this guy is technically i
mean it's definitely statutory rape
but would you call this guy a pedophile
he's definitely
a pervert it's an interesting line i
mean and that's the thing is this is not
the first time i've seen robert
pattinson play a sleazy character who
seduces an underage
chick but this is obviously that much
more just intimate and unsettling and
yeah
just to watch him play this character
who you can see how people would be
suckered in by his
charm and then to see him turn he does
play a lot
under the surface and i feel like that's
part of the thing is that keeps his
character or his performance for being
that you're like okay we get it you can
act thing is because all that bravado on
top is
hiding what's underneath yeah i mean the
narrator helps uh
establish that right away when you see
the character yeah that's true
yeah it does but he brings that to the
performance um
excellent and yeah to get this out of
the way paul
pj pandemic jones uh he said i love this
movie i thought it was great all around
with fantastic acting my favorite scene
personally was when arvin confronts
preacher preston in the church what was
your favorite
scene in the movie and why yeah that is
my favorite scene in the movie i'm
highlighting this specific one because
several guys asked about specific scenes
but this one
was my favorite scene this was like the
culmination moment and this is the scene
we've all been waiting for when watching
it
they deliver like it's such a great
build i love when tom holland goes in
there points the gun even though you
have a narrator in here you could have
had a moment
where the narrator breaks into the scene
and goes but he had to know the truth
first or something like that yeah
and then you just watch him play this
game this like
to the making up these lies this story
and you're watching and i love the way
robert pattinson was reacting to him the
whole time where
he's kind of getting off on the story at
first then he starts getting slowly
suspicious that escalation
it was a beautifully acted seat that was
a
beautiful scene and for anticipation of
wanting to see tom hall and robert
pattinson come to the screen together
they gave us this one scene with them
that was the highlight of the of the
movie to me that was
that was the scene yeah yeah i i would i
would say any scene where tom holland
faces off with somebody with a gun is my
favorite scene
because there are at least three of
those moments and i thought they were
all really terrific and they all
really gripped me yeah i would say the
the scene between them and the church is
probably the centerpiece although the
scene
i have thought back to the most and that
crushed my heart the biggest
was when lenora accidentally hangs
herself and the whole reaction when tom
holland runs in and he's like
trying to lift her body like that was
such an
uncomfortably intimate wrenching
moment that yeah that scene has sort of
been on my mind since then so i don't
know if it's my favorite but it's
definitely one of the most impactful to
me you see this is where you and i think
will really disagree on that scene
i actually got and someone did highlight
it uh that specific scene here and i'm
gonna go back to the performances in a
minute but jordan
shea did say the main scene with the
sister in the barn left a pit in my
stomach the
entire time it was on screen it was like
since they gave the contextual narration
of her scene she realized she and the
baby be okay
really re misdirected me for some reason
and they hung on the frame for a while
no pun intended
especially the one with tom's character
holding her up i really like the way
that was shot and
captured and the performance was awesome
on tom holland's end of when he's
holding
lenora's body and the door keeps getting
slamming
shut again calling for anybody to notice
it feels very
realistic and desperate i actually kind
of got annoyed with the movie for some
it was the only time it was the only
time for a movie that is
very dramatic and very heavy and very
bleak
it was the only time in the movie and i
feel like i'm probably outnumbered here
by by a large margin with the narrator
saying i i i she realized she'd be okay
and then she slips and dies i'm like oh
gosh
you don't have to hammer in the the
drama here weakness
you don't have to yeah i'm like you
don't have to just hammer it even more
like yeah i thought to me i was feeling
a little bit like
manipulated into it but on the flip side
i can also see the version of it where
that's probably a very realistic
situation that's happened to many people
where they can feel
like you know oh i don't want to go
through with this an accident happens
and they end up dying even though they
actually didn't want to go through with
it
like that's very realistic and i get
that but in terms of when it was placed
in the movie
for some reason i was just yes like i
already get your i already get how
[ __ ] dark you are right yeah you
don't need to like
shove this on me now so i actually got
pulled out by that moment but i also
feel like i'm probably in the minority
on that to make it clear i'm
specifically referring to the fact that
there was a narration moment
that she didn't want to go through with
it not the fact that she actually killed
herself that part i
thought was appropriate for the movie it
was more of that extra sting
of she didn't actually want to go
through with it at the last split second
no i mean that's fair and i mean there
are also a lot of gray things i think
that you can argue and dissect about
this movie and i think it touches on one
of them which is that idea of god and
what actually exists on those terms
because the movie starts out with that
place of um
you know them being concerned that like
you're supposed to marry this this one
person i promised god that if you came
back you would marry this person that
doesn't happen and then all these sort
of things
come out of that or do they and i felt
like that was one of those moments i
guess that kind of struck that chord
again
but fair but yeah i can see also why it
would pull you out cause it is a moment
that's purely for us
it's purely for the audience you know to
give us that information
yeah especially because being told to me
in that moment i probably would have
found it more impactful
if the narrator didn't say something you
could kind of just see it in the
performance
that's just a personal touch that i
would have preferred
i could see you know and because i feel
like sometimes a narrator comes in when
he's not entirely necessary there are
times i find it very charming but we'll
talk more about that
soon i want to go back to the
performances though because the thing
that i thought was underwhelming
were the portrayal of the female
characters ex
for some exceptions i thought lenora was
wonderfully portrayed i thought she was
great yeah i thought
the sandy character by riley was it
cough
what is that i think even with those two
performances being pretty solid i still
felt that most of the rich writing and
character portrayals
were all like a billion percent
and this isn't woke greg and john
stepping in this is just what the movie
gave me that when i walked away i'm like
man the performances
i don't think about the women especially
when you got an actress like
haley bennett in here who i thought did
every all the actresses did a fine job
they all did a really good job but
there's no denying that
it's just the highlight performances are
all like sebastian stan jason
correct robin pants tom holland bill
skarsgard you know and you spend all
your time really dissecting them and
that's the thing is i liked a lot of the
female
characters and i thought there were a
lot of very charming moments featuring
those female characters but yeah like
all of the
content and all of the diving into
character depth is for
a lot of the male roles that's the thing
is the sandy story feels like she is
trying to
ascend being an object in this situation
being an accessory
to this situation that's spiraling out
of control and there's a tragedy to the
way her character
winds up but that's the closest i feel
like the movie gets to really
substantiating any of its female
characters and i can't find the question
right now i think i forgot to screenshot
it but someone asked
like do you think sandy deserved to die
and yeah i do
horrible person i like the moment of
fleeting hope of you know she oh she's
trying to get out of this and she
come on guys she's but you've been a
serial killer
she's still going through with most of
this you know
um like she's not a good person and then
you even have that moment where she's
looking at the photos
as much as she's feeling conflicted
about some of this she she's kind of she
still enjoys
reminiscing at some of these moments
yeah i actually thought it structurally
speaking that was a cool way that played
out when you find out there's a blank in
there
yeah that was one of those narration
combined with going to a flashback
moment
that i was like ah that's clever like i
i really did appreciate that but yeah i
did think she
deserved to die but i did really like
that standoff that brief
moment with her and tom holland when
they have the the guns pointed at them i
thought was really well done
seemed to fit the movie's morality the
way she went out we're gonna start
getting into some more like specific
plot stuff but while we're on the
performances there's a lot of credit to
the performer even with the actresses
there's a lot of credit to the
performances because
the parts i'm a little bit conflicted
about story-wise
of being in the movie jason clark
riley and the sebastian stan stuff
really focusing on
them because i really liked it only
because
i thought everything on a technical
scale was captured wonderful
everything's really interesting
everything's real yeah that's the thing
it's all really [ __ ] interesting yes
the performances are great i love the
grimness of it and i love what they're
exploring
however and when by the time the movie
wrapped up did that even really need to
be in the movie
because i actually i didn't know where
this movie was going 99
of the time after robert pattinson died
everything suddenly became very
predictable to me already my mom was
going oh okay he's going to go back home
jason clark and we're going to pick him
up he's got probably gonna kill them off
sebastian
like my mind like just started going
like uh and then sure enough it
of course didn't play out a hundred
percent like i imagine and i still like
the execution of those scenes there was
something about
them that felt a little bit out of place
that doesn't quite fully mesh with me in
terms of the grand scheme of the script
and the story on hand
i know this is based on a book and so
maybe in the book it probably works a
lot better
but for here i only really liked it a
lot because of everything on screen
yeah but then when i took by the time we
wrapped i was like i don't even think we
really needed that you probably could
have done a little bit more of it was
just like expanding on the other stuff
with like the preacher and
and and like keeping it just strictly
robert pattinson and tom holland and
that
whole showdown per se but i still really
liked it but that's a credit to the
performances of even though i'm
conflicted on how
much i thought it was necessary to keep
in the adaptation i really liked it a
lot be
primarily due to the performances yeah
that's
yeah i'd say that's like the saving
grace that keeps everything afloat no
matter what is that the performances are
great and the
it's beautifully captured and they
actually shot this on film which was
like a nice
change of pace i noticed that right away
yeah it was really refreshing yeah and
it really does bring that
40s 50s 60s aesthetic to life and yeah
i'm sitting here and i'm thinking back
on it and i feel like yeah it'll take me
a minute to sort of put together if i
feel like everything was absolutely
necessary but i do see where you're
going with that yeah is because you do
kind of flip into plot mode once you get
into a certain point in the movie
i guess yeah i could see that being kind
of frustrating it was unique in the
sense of i'm not used to seeing this
kind of story in a movie
but the way it actually unfolds wasn't
the most unique way of how i thought it
like the execution is what it's all
about
and i thought the execution was was
definitely different but in terms of the
beats
some of the story lines were hitting i
don't know there was something about it
that just felt
it was very separate and detached from
the main storyline which is the
bloodline and
you know the the harvest yeah there's in
this just general ecosystem of sin
and god fearing it's more of a
conflicted thing as opposed to i'm
i'm very concrete on my opinion here and
after watching it i wouldn't want it to
not be in the movie
yeah it's one of those things that yeah
it begs you to sit around and kind of
ponder it because then you have to think
is this scene necessary because it's
dealing with the overall theme of the
movie not so much you know like the main
characters not that this movie is like a
one character movie but yeah
it is one of those things that maybe
some of these scenes fit
more in just the overall themes or
something and that's a thing that i
think every viewer is going to have to
decide on for themselves because some
people
don't appreciate that level of opacity
and it might not be as deep as it thinks
it is
yeah so well i want to read a couple
questions back to back here
um and a lot of game wars like story
structures stuff like that now
batman says how did you guys like the
structure of this movie did you find the
flashback sequences out of place at
times
and among uh sorry if i'm saying that
wrong do you think the movie would have
been better without the narration i'm
usually not a fan of narrations but i
think it was used extremely well here
i was delighted to find out that is i
didn't know it was based on a book so i
got two pieces of information all on
once
on the credits when it says based on a
book by donald ray pollock
narration by donald republic oh that's
cool you didn't notice that
the guy who always states that credit i
know look at me
yeah is novel by him and then he
narrated it too and i thought that was
really cool
i have to agree with you first in the
narration i'm usually someone
i've obviously said a couple of things
here and there that were like ah it
wasn't there were some parts where i
didn't need the narration
but overall i actually really liked the
narration and added to that gothic
southern tale vibe what was great about
the narration was that the narrator
had an opinionated voice yes
it wasn't just conveying information
it's not the necessarily the omniscient
narrator yeah yeah
it's not like the narrator who's just
telling you [ __ ] because you won't get
what's going on you know
yeah like he had opinions and swear
words
and you almost feel like this was a guy
who was around for these things and
just retelling you the tale yeah yeah
that's what i thought was wonderful
about the use of narration and
and i and i like the structure it's an
odd structure it's a very
different kind of structure unless
you've seen place beyond the pines it's
not so weird
it's not even exactly that structure of
that movie because that one's pretty
linear and consistent in what they're
doing it has like three chapters yeah
whereas this i mean yeah you jump to
flashbacks when necessary but you do
kind of go linearly from the 40s to the
60s
yeah and you are also just changing it's
like that like this movie
spreads out among its protagonists too
it's like they're all related but in
tangential ways so it almost has an
anthology vibe
well i think the structure and narration
go hand in hand because
there are some things that i thought
were neat in how they were
done because let's look at the mia
wasikowska character
you learn right like early on when the
whole when she's holding the baby
her baby and the narrator says like they
found her body
seven daily uh seven years later or
something like that i forget the exact
detail we know she's gonna die that day
and it's probably gonna be at the hands
of dudley yeah
like you know he's you know that's uh
that's when it's going to happen
they tell you that before you even see
that scene
and that actually elevated the tension
of that scene
when he does uh jabber in the throat
with a screwdriver
that was actually elevated as opposed to
if the narrator told me that tom
holland's gonna shoot robert pattinson
i would not have liked that yeah but
sometimes depending on how they chose to
present certain scenes i thought were
good and then there are other parts
where that could have felt jarring
without the narration
for the most part i thought they knew
when to use the narration to intrigue
you for what's to come
yeah and when to not spoil something
like when you
first see sandy and uh carl jason
clark's character right
the first time you see them there's a
tidbit about
you know their victims and killers and
[ __ ] i was like what
oh holy [ __ ] that's what i was expecting
yeah yeah and like this is the first
time they're meeting and it
and i guess in a way like i thought
thematically it's cool of how that ties
in
with the same day that bill skarsgard
met
the love of his life you know like the
that's the exact same day
so i thought in terms of destiny and
faked and whatever
of how that tied in was neat and helps
justify
its story being in the movie more that's
when i thought the narration was uh was
cool and the structure was neat
yeah i would totally agree it just it
adds a certain fairy taleness to it that
kind of i think offsets a little bit of
that bleakness
and yeah for the most part i thought it
was really appropriate it made me
reminded of the fact that this is a book
adaptation but in a way that i thought
was pleasant and also yeah there are a
couple of times where
it probably went to serve for a scene
that was cut out or unclear
and that's when yes narration is lazy
but overall i
yeah i appreciated it as an aesthetic
addition to the experience
so yeah i don't think i would remove
much of it yvonne
de peretti uh is asking what are the
correlations between good and evil god
and devil
in this film that you noticed my first
reaction to this question you know this
movie is called the devil all the time
most of these characters are
our christian are they baptist what is
the exact religion they are i
don't do they specify what they think
yeah but yeah you know one of those uh
sort of smaller sects that's a little
bit more you know
praise i feel like they're southern
baptists probably the impression i'm
getting right what i thought was
really great about what they do with the
presence of the devil in this movie
a good chunk of the acts that they're
doing uh of these terrible actions
are in the intention that they're doing
this for god
or with god in mind in some way shape or
form yeah
but these are really heinous
um sinister devil-like actions you know
yeah so
it made me think of that that phrase of
the greatest trick the devil ever pulled
what was the the bunny out of the hat i
was uh
happy here was throwing his voice
was how did he get that card to that
watermelon man oh
dude must be pretty sharp damn he threw
that
that's impressive yeah that devil he
should take this to vegas he was sodding
him
the greatest trick the devil ever pulled
was having you think he wasn't real
and like all these people are like god
faith obsessed you know some people are
doing this
uh intentionally like you got this
preacher character
who's like the devil has infiltrated the
church and then you got
character like roy of i'm gonna i'm
gonna kill my wife and prove how
connected i am i'm gonna resurrect
my wife from the dead then you've got
bill skarsgard who's who's desperate for
jesus to save his his wife's life and he
offers up a sacrifice like these are
terrible terrible things these people
are doing
that are representing all all kinds of
sins
lusts wrath envy all these different
kinds of sins all over the place
sebastian stan's character like goes to
serve like the greed
thematically there are reasons why i
think like sebastian stan and jason
clarkson are all justified to be in here
overall what i thought was really
interesting about what they did with it
was that quote that came to mind of the
greatest trick the devil ever pulled was
have you think he wasn't real because
like guys see that was [ __ ] working
amongst all you guys
and because it's established right away
with bill skarsgard on the battlefield
where they find that dead body um well
he's not dead yet but he's
he's crucified this soldier is crucified
immediately puts an image in your head
of well that's what crucifixion was you
know we often see the cross and
associated with this like heavenly
jesus christ you know he died on the
cross but it's but the cross has become
symbolic violent symbolic but really
it's a yeah it's a symbol for
punishment torture torture like it's
evil right i thought like structurally
speaking
and starting off with bill skarsgard's
character what his
traumatic memory is from the war is this
violent image of a man being crucified
to the cross
which is you know off like different
than what we normally associate with
what a cross means now
i thought really hammered in that theme
and does pull back that veil of oh yeah
that's right
crucifixions are more than christ
they're actually i mean even for christ
it was a
form of torture and punishment but
that's what these characters are
enduring throughout this whole movie
through their faith torture and
punishment yeah i mean this this movie
seemed
to me like it's yeah approaching at
least that idea of god
from multiple angles because you know
you start the movie out with something
that's more benevolent like i prayed to
god every day
and if he brought you back i'll have you
marry this specific person
and it also makes you it makes you
wonder then about god and the devil
and coincidence because you know that's
one of the first events of the movie and
life
for everyone connected to bill scarface
goes way downhill
after that in really terrible ways you
witness the godlessness in the name of
god through so
many different characters and there are
characters like sebastian stan who
seems more like an atheist type
character to me or like a faithless like
he doesn't even have this aspiration
he's just
purely of the physical world and those
greedy desires and whatever because he
is kind of like a
pathetic character compared to everybody
else we have a couple of
preachers in here who are deranged by
the end of it you have tom holland who
is the only person who did these
terrible sinful acts but arguably with
the best
intent of any character in the whole
movie so yeah
he's the only character with a real arc
he is and and yeah and and everybody he
dispatches
pretty much earned it somehow yeah and
so
it does make you wonder about what you
know
forms of wrath are divine or are you
know
the opposite of that and what you know
it's like what sins are godly and what
you know seemingly good acts are
devilish because there's that whole
thing with robert pattins and we're the
first scene
he has with lenore at first it is kind
of like i mean you know where it's going
but at first you're like oh yeah you
know i can see
what the you know benevolence is trying
to be here and then pretty quickly you
see that
maybe i don't know it's a comment on
like if you're married to god and you
have all these restrictions in your life
it's going to breed these pent-up
ways in which you compartmentalize and
justify your own dysfunctions and
enact them on people i feel like it is a
movie that is just exploring so much in
the god and the devil
you know manifesto that you know i don't
know if there's a specific
conclusion it's trying to draw yeah
that's why i wanted to
i wanted to go off of this question next
what and vikkis 1995 who says
what do you think the overall idea of
the
file as we of the film is what might say
as we see the plot rotates around
god church and prayers but did not
conclude with a message
or idea it was a weird ambiguous ending
because there's so much that obviously
that we can draw as you
just see right now from us talking that
we can draw from from the film
thematically but then by the time it was
wrapping up i thought for
character for tom hollands uh arvin yeah
for arvin
was a great arc for him because he
literally buries the past
at the end of that movie all his wounds
leaving the house behind
this association with sebastian's dad
yeah memory i didn't even feel like that
really went to go serve his ark having
to kill him off you know that's what i
mean like there's something about that
it just it needed
a little bit of extra contact i'm not
sure what it is that was missing for me
there
because it didn't feel like it really
tied in necessary because it could have
ended right there where he goes there he
buries
he buries everything and then hits like
he even buries the luger the one gift
that his dad left behind
this act of violence that he committed
he's burying it and then he's going off
and
like i like the ambiguous open-ended
nature for his character of
he's taking his chance on a stranger
something he doesn't trust and then you
don't know where his
past is going but all he has now is the
future in terms of
what the movie's really talking about i
suddenly was a little bit
confused on wait a minute we explored a
lot i know it doesn't have to be about
one thing yeah i get that what exactly
are we talking about right now
by the time we got to the closing
moments i was like what what exactly is
this about what
in terms of god i get what i get with
the arving character with
god in church and the faith and all that
what what happened there yeah
and i mean i wonder if it's there for
contrast and i mean that the devil all
the time
title significance comes in and i feel
like that is obviously very well lived
in the movie that every character's
fighting off a devil of some sort for
the whole movie yeah it almost struck me
as just the ending is
it's a godless world because everybody
dies cold and alone and terribly
and you know for some tragic
circumstances usually that they brought
upon themselves
or i mean in case of like the people who
were murdered by the couple you know by
just
unlucky circumstance it makes me wonder
if the part of the point is we have so
much
angst there's so much rot around this
idea of god-fearing and religion and
it's such
a staple of society during you know the
40s 50s and 60s in america i mean we're
sort of
in that transition i feel like because
once you reach the 60s you have a whole
mess of liberation
that kind of challenges a lot of you
know religious tenets
sure sure um but lieutenant tenet
oh it's connected i feel like this
probably is deep down getting at
just what god and the devil are as
delusions of man i almost think it
doesn't really matter if the movie is
trying to say that god and the devil are
real or not because
you can just see how the mess of life
creates all this sin
and pain and how god doesn't really it's
true i mean
it's like i i imagine that it's really
like uh i mean from you talking about
that i imagine that maybe
the devil's not it's not so much about
it being an external force
it's more about the devil within all of
us yeah and how that
causes the problems and he lets that
devil go by you know
burying it paco salazar's asking i did
like this film but felt that even though
it's a slow burn it felt rushed to me do
you think it would have worked more as a
mini series or is it fine the way it
is i've had i saw a few questions that
came in about pacing and such
i thought this was the best one that
encompassed it thank you pac paco the
only reason i think that
is because i feel like all this weird
conflict i have about the jason clark
and sandy and sebastian sands storyline
probably would have worked way better in
a mini series
like in terms of all these characters
you know because the movie's like two
hours and 18 minutes
and i feel like you would have been more
focused and a little sharper
if you didn't have that part and you
only focused on this whole thing with
the preacher lenore and then maybe it
ends with tom holland like going back
home burying right
or heck bring him back only once he's
killed their sister
his sister yeah or something something
like that right i don't know the book
i i haven't looked up what the
differences are between the book and the
movie so whoever asked if it's a good
adaptation
yeah i don't know but to be totally uh
honest
i didn't find it rushed i thought it was
actually executed really well
i thought that pacing was fine and there
were things that i think would have been
better in a three-hour movie versus
a two-hour and 18 minute movie that
being said i don't think it was rushed
and there is a version of this where i
think a mini series
probably would have been uh a little bit
better
that being said for what we got i really
liked it a lot 8.5 out of 10 for me yeah
yeah i thought this was solid it's
a situation where i'm like this could
have easily been a mini series but i'm
not
upset at the moment that it wasn't julia
did bernardo she's asking uh love the
channel mike
thank you my question is what were the
specific plot points or decisions made
by characters that were the most
shocking to you
and then we had another ques we have had
several questions that were asking about
because people have been really turned
off by the violence and the grim nature
of it
which i don't know i mean i'm not so i
watched something i'm not surprised
that's in the movie no
it's deviled all the time it's a it's an
r-rated netflix movie
it seemed like the kind of movie that
was going to get harshly violent
every so often it felt very menacing and
sinister from the trailers you know i'm
like well
and the other thing is you see the
rating and you're like graphic nudity oh
is there going to be some explicit say
oh god no they're just going to be like
severed genitalia and things like that i
mean that was
that was the shock that was pretty dis
that was shocking because it's not
like it's not a close-up on it but then
your eye is drawn to how everything
feels very clean and crisp and then all
of a sudden you've got this very clear
shot where there should be genitals
yeah yeah yeah so that was disturbing
and uh you know like there's some like
graphic shots of course there's a whole
montage of their
like murder spree done in negative photo
negatives
which have made it weirdly more eerie
the fact that it wasn't
all developed photos yeah so you're
looking at
the inside out images and it's got this
ironic ish music over top
and yeah it makes it this weird haunting
human experience because it
captures both the perverseness and the
weird joy the characters are getting out
of it
to me the most shocking moment the
genuine shocking moment
came very early on early on for what the
length of this movie is
it was when uh bill skarsgard kills the
dog
yes that was shocking full transparency
i knew that the dog was gonna die
oh yeah i didn't know don't know why the
dog was gonna die he didn't know what
the dog was gonna become
i mean i knew the dog was gonna die
because original's gonna watch us with
olivia
she can't handle animal death so there's
websites where they tell you
what happened so i was like can you just
look up if this dog i saw his dog in the
trailer
it looks like the dog's gonna die and
then she found out the dog dies but i
didn't know any details
as to what led to the dog dying or how
the dog dies
and it's just like [ __ ] goes crazy in
there
you know man i thought okay there's
gonna be some like villainous act
or maybe these bad guys these people who
are bullying them or they're the ones
who are gonna you know beat uh who are
gonna kill the dog or something yeah
they're gonna get revenge but then for
it to be a sacrifice and to see the
extent of where this character is going
and then
the desperation how far he goes with it
even though it's it's mainly implied you
get one
clear shot with the flashlight pov with
sebastian stan
where you see that he like spread out
this dog that's decaying
on the cross which is a very disturbing
image covered in bugs
it's it's really it's really gross and
the effect that it's having on young
arvin of i'm not gonna pray anymore
don't worry i'm gonna i'm gonna go down
there when dad's asleep and i'm gonna
take you off and give you a proper like
all of that was the most disturbing
stuff to me i was a little worried for
that child actor too with some of those
scenes because like the way bill's
guard is like handling the back of his
head and forcing him to play
yeah please be careful with that boy
yeah
yeah that was uh that was probably the
most uh uh
shocking stuff to me but overall i'm not
perturbed in the sense of this
movie you know yeah i mean there's
definitely some really uncomfortable
stuff when robert pattinson is like
seducing girls and things like that
there are some very very uncomfortable
just like
human character decisions but in terms
of like shocking moments that's
yeah what comes to mind is just those
occasions of violence for very very
twisted motives
yeah you know because it's not just
about the dog it's it's why he's doing
it and the desperate
like at first you want to be mad and you
want to be like you monster and then
you're like oh
i get why you're doing it and now i just
feel bad for everybody
yeah i mean the time period thing helps
make a difference
well if this was modern day i'd be like
you [ __ ] yeah you're here
and that's the thing too is it does
remind you of a time in which things
were so much more isolated and
you know there was probably so much more
loneliness and so much
more just opportunity to fall into
either these nasty traps or
into these nasty habits because of the
limitations
of you know your place in the world
fabricio rodas
uh he asked do you all think tom or bill
could get nominated personally
yes um i hope so you say bill you mean
bill skarsgard or saying like we know
robert oh no robert bobby
yes um you know one of those uh one of
those real small supporting actors
i actually feel like out of as great as
tom holland is in the movie
i under the impression that if anyone
were to get nominated
it would actually be either robert
pattinson or bill skarsgard
i think it would be one of those two
because tom holland is
he i think he would be qualified as as
lead actor
yeah i'm not saying this to diminish any
part of the
the strong performance areas here just
thinking about what the way the [ __ ]
oscars are i was like
you either got the really strong
supporting haunted tragic
supporting performance or you got the
really big supporting performance
oh look what a despicable role you took
on yeah yeah
yeah i i think it would be uh it would
be one of those i feel like the
obvious one is more robert pattinson
pats is flashier right now
oh yeah it's way flashier and subdued in
all the right scenes
man he does get some disturbing ass
scenes though because it's that it does
it's that thing where you can see how he
can get away with it because
there's sexual assault in this movie
yeah but it's
never in other than what they almost do
with uh
lenora what they almost do with her with
like the paper bag or the bullies
yeah i was like oh crap like when that
happened like is this movie gonna go
there oh
don't go there yeah um i didn't like i i
can't stand watching
scenes like that at all he's sexually
assaulting these women but he's getting
them to agree to oh he's manipulating
them
manipulating them and then were they
feigning ignorance yeah where they start
falling for him you know and they're
their young girl
it's disturbing as hell and
dif and different than what i would you
know
like i thought this movie might go the
oh he's going to forcefully do stuff
but here yeah here this is uh
he get he could lie his way out of here
if he needs to you know well and that
was
that was a thing you know like at first
i was like oh no he's going to get away
with this because of course people are
going to believe the preacher
and i do think it's funny that this only
just popped into my mind now but like of
all the characters
tom owen is the one you know kind of
leaves faith and he makes it through the
movie the best by the end
he's the one guy who's like not trying
to do anything in
on behalf of god for any reason you know
yeah and for whatever reason he does
make it through
and he does like bring righteous
judgment upon some pretty bad people who
seem to be under the impression that
they're getting close to or spreading
the word of god
yeah yeah to wrap this up i think tying
it back into the whole mini series
discussion
that's where i think a lot of this could
have i really liked it i really liked
this movie
very grossing yeah um but i think some
things are better
justified in terms of exploring stuff
focusing on it in its plot because it's
much easier to look at a movie and go we
didn't need this
we didn't need this um but you can
unpack but even stuff that i was like i
don't know if we needed this i was
always very engaged with
lenora getting bullied at school and him
you know taking on the bullies and
beating them up you know i
i and but i also thought that was
representative of his character of
showing how he was becoming like his dad
in certain ways
yeah you know in fact yeah and when that
scene first comes up when his dad goes
and does the same i'm like
i bet we're gonna see him do that later
yeah and i thought they handled yeah
just his growth visually
very well and and yeah i mean it is one
of those things where just because this
all takes place in a relatively small
cluster of areas
you know it kind of makes sense that all
these characters would cross paths at
some point
so there is also just that kind of
magical coincidence happenstance
essence and what does that have to do
with god and the devil in the back of
your mind yeah
you know and i think that's probably
again one of those saving graces for
this as a movie as opposed to a series
because yeah at a series you can unpack
everybody in a different way yeah and
there's more justifiable
um purposes to just be like let's just
explore this part in this person's life
you know even if it's not you know the
most essential to the grand scheme you
know
all right guys well the devil all the
time what'd you guys think of it do you
prefer this review format
i know it's like longer for us to you
know cut up and put together and all
that but at the same time i
i personally i've just been wanting to
mix up our review style
interactive i feel like i personally
enjoy doing this one a lot makes it more
fun subscribe to the real rejects leave
your thoughts down below
and uh do you think tom holland should
get an oscar nomination why the hell not
catch you guys soon
you